[Applause]
busted that good we must have done good
Neil deGrasse Tyson and what can do we
do to fight against the anti
intellectual movement in America I I
blamed some of that on the the attitude
that so many intellectuals had towards
those who are not as smart as they were
we have a long history of just smart
people discounting the views and the
opinions and feelings of those who are
not as well educated and that could
really piss off an entire demographic so
at least I is an educator I not
distinguish one for I just bring
everybody with you together to empower
their critical thinking but some people
don't want to learn know you have to
admit what you sound like the teacher
who say these students don't want to
learn rather than indict your own
teaching habits as failing okay I mean
you know you can't let everybody off the
hook it's not like everybody's a good
person you try harder with them I mean I
I don't like antics an educator I can't
accept that so you think you could teach
Donald Trump something no I can it's
like guys in dolls it's a bet you pick
anybody I could do all right Donald
Trump I bet you $1,000 you cannot teach
Donald Trump that the stealth bomber is
not literally invisible moments
a thousand dollars without a so we will
need it Lindy's tomorrow people are
thinking that that teaching is handing
someone information to replace
information that they had that is false
her as an aspect of teaching but it's
not the fundamental dimension of it it's
getting a person to understand why their
thoughts are wrong to begin with and
then think it's their own epiphany good
luck yeah he's not gonna have an
epiphany because anyway innovations in
science and technology are the engines
of tomorrow's economy and they will
drive our health our wealth and our
security if you invest in science I like
well that will be the country that you
always wanted it to be he'll say that's
why I'm abolish and Obamacare yeah to
the part about me yeah it's not anti
intellectualism I think it's anti
science anti empirical truth that's
bigger the bigger danger because because
we are not taught in school what science
is and how and why it works what we're
taught is a satchel of facts and they
spit it back in the test and you move on
to your next class science is a way of
querying the world it's a way of knowing
what is true and what is not and
establishing the objective reality in
which we all must function if you don't
have those capabilities and you but gain
power oh my gosh
that's the beginning of the end of an
informed democracy there is a
large-sized out of this country that is
not excuse me
objective reality you get them well and
they're not critical thinkers as well
yeah and you have to reach them where
they are and it's sometimes and you're
okay one of my two books that are on the
bestseller list right now has been on
the bestsellers for 71 weeks bobbing in
tidewaters of Trump books that have come
and gone so that gives me hope
okay somebody out there who cares about
how many copies does it bestseller so
it's highly variable so just about how
many copies has this I know the total
number is not what the base tell me how
many copies the book is in total yeah
yeah million can change a million
million out of a country of 320 million
yeah okay so it's still not a lot of the
people who yeah what people in other
countries read English yeah I know but
we're talking about America oh I want to
say guess conveyed some sixty
translations also and if you don't marry
okay here's a point it is in a sea of
Trump books that come back and forth so
if you're gonna talk about popular books
it's sitting there in the middle of what
words book on fear and and yeah all of
them there is always a small percentage
of people who will be bright a million
okay I'm liking the number a million
yeah I like it too but it's one three
hundredths of the country April Ryan do
you think we should bring back the equal
time rule yes yes and what is that the
first of all let me break it down in
science
[Laughter]
my brother sorry I wasted that
tenderloin on me so okay so so forth for
you for those of you who don't know I
remember when President Trump thin
candidate Trump was calling on Morning
Joe when he liked Joe Scott yes I do
other networks well you didn't hear the
other candidates calling in they could
have because the equal time rule is gone
it's a it's gone they have not realized
yeah so if he they could have done it as
well if there was a rule that if there
was the rule still in effect right the
president Trump would be on the air and
they would have to give it time to other
candidates V that is no longer effect
and that's one of the reasons why you
want Donald Trump won that free oh my
question is Bill why didn't the other
candidates have the hood spot to go in
and say let me do it it was like there
was scared Donald Trump plate the street
so he won in your room they were into
this thus now there aren't where for
this and this is not how it's a city he
plays this Street game
Evelynn how should America deal with
Russia Post Trump oh my gosh if there is
a post Trump I mean I think the way that
his administration that is to say
everyone but him in our government is
which is firmly is spelling out to
Russia that if they continue with this
really horrible behavior you know
invading other countries occupying them
messing with our elections continuing to
mess with our elections poisoning and
killing people in other countries you
know I mean I can go on and on if
there's a list of like 20 things if they
keep doing all that stuff that most we
are ruining them mostly our elections
that to me is so much more Ukraine I
hope you're happy but I don't care as
much about Ukraine as I do about [ __ ]
with our election unless a major that's
like way up here and then the rest of it
sorry about the poison on our country
yes but Ukraine is also an attack of
America and as much as it's an attack on
the right of a country to say I'm a
sovereign country we this sovereign
Ukrainian people want to be associated
with NATO and the European Union and the
West and we want to be democratic and we
don't want this guy in the Kremlin
telling us how to live our lives yeah so
the answer to your question is wouldn't
send troops for it but we should be
stronger in it and and we didn't I mean
we seems to train them I think so what
do we do so we need to do more of the
firm stuff because they won't cooperate
with us until we are sufficiently across
the board consistently firm all the way
up to the president knows cooperating
Russian and American astronauts
yeah they don't see it okay calling
other countries
I can't go too far on this and I'm can I
call you kneel or doctor doctor needle
they are it is a troubled world up in
space with Russia and China I'll just
leave it at that so it's good bass
station is one thing and commercial
space is one thing maybe it'll lead add
immorality into the future right
space junk you've got your room there
yeah max what do you think people are
fascinated why do you think people are
fascinated with doomsday dystopian
futures I mean I think there there's
always this fear especially in America
because I think there's something very
deep about our isolationism and we're oh
wait you know remember we most of us
came from someplace else and we escaped
a lot of us escaped hardship our
ancestors escaped hardship to come here
and there's always a subconscious fear
that what we escaped will one day find
us and I think that's why there's always
this terror particularly because when
times are even good you have an
explosion of post-apocalyptic movies TV
video games so many movies about after
the bomb went off right and it's
horrible and that's scary because like I
say movies do come true it's always
there and and if I can go back to what
you said about Russia I think something
happened recently that we need to be
very aware of is that the Russians just
rioted because Putin raised the level of
retirement when you can retire I think
it was 65 average Russian man dies at 66
and what that did is it exploded the
myth that Russians will be able to
sacrifice for the motherland and pay any
price right and that's been the idea
that oh no no we can take the pain
Russia will be invincible and that's
[ __ ]
we can hurt them we can make them bleed
and the Russians have been fighting in
the gray zone they've used economic
warfare information warfare cyber
warfare we don't do any of that we used
to do air right and it's time to get
back in the game and it's time to make
Ivan bleed here here
all right Thank You panel let's end on
[Applause]
thank you folks
[Applause]